it's a very famous sofa very famous sofa
with fame comes the ultimate accolade a
waxwork now kylie you've been in Madame
Tussauds how many up there's been loads
verse alive maybe five different ones
but they've I think they've just changed
it again well this I think this is this
the last one
this isn't the new one this is the last
one I think was like second to last and
then they had to have to replace spits
of it because so many members of public
we're doing this three three vomits the
wax wore down are you standing now I'm
sat down safe I'm actually on my bottom
very good now M Cameron have you seen
your wax work i I think I have the
Charlie's Angels yeah it's really pissed
for its hey how should I say what's the
word I was using before it's an
approximation yes of a person a person
yeah this is Cameron Diaz this is the
Hollywood I aim wax we do I think the
Halle way not about this is this is not
madam juice all standard yeah
very more but that is so it's nothing
there's not even a passing resent the
hair good yes something hard in is it
true Russell you don't like wax work I
hate them they're creepy
absolutely they give me the [__] and
anytime that anybody puts one up we at
we we have someone for years will you
chase them down he made them melted milk
that mean lumpy thing so this one just
last for long again it's already gone
that that's ten years ago we pursued
those people and it's gone chopped off
his head oh is it just a tight and look
how [__] that is absolutely ridiculous I
just think it's such a weird thing I
have just no desire and they you know
manager salad send you a letter and as
you getting up nothing's not just not
interested in it actually funny enough
we were ringing round wax museums in
Australia to see if there was one of you
there to show a picture of us and one of
them said no no we don't have a waxwork
of Russell Crowe but we have a letter
from Russell do you know this letter so
they wrote to you to say how is just not
one of the abusive ones no no no this is
such a sweet letter here's the here's
the letter so it says dear Peter Sorry
mate no interest at all in being made
out of wax please do not pursue this any
further you don't about mission over
blessing apart from that hope you and
your family are doing well
did you see that terrible Kylie wax when
I showed in the monologue this is so bad
I mean it's really so if I could have a
template of your letter
next time why'd you have to say love you
though the one was you kneeling down
though it's kind of attractive they're
not using that one anymore
no hot drinks on their place actually
Richard is there a waxwork review we
could get peppermint alarms does not
seem to be there are you sure there's no
backtalk of you I'm pretty sure because
some fans of yours posted a picture on
line right so you telling me this is
actually you in this picture not a
waxwork
that picture as you can see I'm
incredibly relaxed this time engaging
with fans fun guy
I'll tackle this big fat kid run around
the ankles smack went down like a sack
of [__] fatty thanks for coming
Virginia is talking everybody's been
talking about